holy that was two and a half hours
of a michaelbay wet dream I swear to God
two and a half hours of Michael Bagon
transformers age of extinction
so transformers age of extinction is the
fourth Transformers in the Transformers
movie franchise it's kind of a departure
because there's a whole new cast in this
movie there's no Shia LaBeouf there's no
Shia LaBeouf shitty parents there's no
shitty John Turturro character Optimus
Prime and the Autobots being hunted down
by the government and this galactic
bounty hunter who's kind of a
transformer also oh really let's just
break this movie down for it honest to
god I don't even know where to start so
we'll start with the character's cousin
true Michael Bay fashion you're here to
watch Autobots and Decepticons fight
each other or at least you know really
cool robot fights or maybe you want the
movie to concentrate on transformers
since it's called transformers Benelli
concentrates on the human being so the
human characters you got Mark Wahlberg a
generic guy who's just kind of down on
his luck so you're like oh I just have
to relate to him he got his super super
sexy hot daughter who was that really
bad actress girl from the last airbender
movie now she's that really bad actress
hot chick from transformers age of
extinction just phone sex voice though I
swear to God every time she talks she
had that kind of whiny twang phone sex
voice Britney Spears singing in the 90s
tone every time she talked I felt like I
had to throw 498 a minute at the screen
don't know why I would even get that
reference cuz no one uses phone texts
anymore cuz we got the Internet
seriously that chick is super hot super
super hot she's great to look at but I'm
not a it doesn't make the movie
any good just means there's a super hot
chick in a really stupid movie he
doesn't get points for that
anything you got this family you're
supposed to root for but in the end you
don't give a not there's just
expendable people kill him if you want
to Stanley Tucci in the movie Stanley
Tucci's always the guy even if he's in a
movie he's the best part of the
movie and I swear to god hand over heart
Michael Bay tried the worst part is when
you see Michael Bay actively try to turn
Stanley Tucci into John de toros
character from the other movies if you
tell Stanley Tucci fights it he has a
couple of good lines but in the end he's
completely wasted he starts throwing out
that shtick Michael Bay humor
but hey we have a whole new crew of
Autobots that we don't care about also
so not only do we have new humans that
we don't give a about we have new
Autobots that we don't give a about
we still have Optimus Prime and
Bumblebee they're the returning ones
it's Optimus Prime bumblebee and
Autobots then no one gives us
Edition and the runtime oh my god
what is the runtime of this monstrosity
I point this movie I was like all the
third act of his movies really boring no
it wasn't the third act it was somewhere
in the second this movie just kept going
and going and going was like oh holy God
it has all the depth of a Michael Bay
movie and seemingly has the runtime of a
Kevin Costner movie a lot of things blow
up in the movie that does for sure a lot
of things blow up but even the special
effects were garbage swear to God the
special effects in this movie looked
worse than any of the other Transformers
movies when they transformed it look
like the CGI look like there
are these new Transformers in this movie
and they break down into little blocks
and they go and they go around and turn
into robots and look like a screensaver
I was like that looks like ps2 if I'm
optimistic it looks like ps3 it clearly
looks like bad CGI layered over
live-action just even to see where this
one dude falls and the cameras over him
and he's falling I was like the chick
who fell through the moon during Game of
Thrones looked a lot better this was
like dick Jones falling in the original
Robocop movie but it's okay cuz we got
Dinobots this time no we don't I guess
you can argue you kind of have Dino but
it's seriously the Dinobots are in this
movie just for raw Optimus Prime to ride
Grimlock or if even if he is Grimlock
he's not actually Grimlock no whatever
says he's Grimlock no one ever says the
names Grimlock slag sludge snarl swoop
none of them they don't even look like
him the t-rex kind of looks like a t-rex
Triceratops sure the pterodactyl has to
has another one that has like three rows
of spines I'm like what are you that
whole thing has been promoted and exists
simply to have Optimus Prime ride him
just ride him and he's Optimus
Prime riding a robot just like this he
might as well turn to the camera be like
shut up it's not gay dude on dude riding
Robo action right here in the fourth
Transformers movie when things blow up
and then blow up and then more ship
blows up and then things blow up and
then blow up blow up blow up blow up
you'd be surprised how bored you got I
think that's Michael Bay's mission in
life is to show people that they can get
bored watching things blow up
maybe he's this crusader he's like I
want to be a good filmmaker that people
really just run after just
because it's visual effects so I'm gonna
make a visual effects orgy of garbage
just so people can be like hey maybe I
don't like that Michael Bay's a crusader
he's doing it for better film ultimately
this movie is exactly what you think
this movie's going to be if you like
that
you'll like this movie if you hate that
you'll hate this movie if you like
hollow characters on top of more hollow
characters and special effects that
really aren't as good as the previous
movies and explosions explosions
explosions and you're gonna
like the movie if you need anything more
than that you're gonna be like this I'm
done the best part of this movie is the
last line you feel like at the end of
this movie you're like oh yeah the next
movie's going to be awesome but no we're
wise to the act now we're not gonna be
fooled again the next movie's not going
to be awesome
honest to god I went into this movie
wanting to like it I was like all right
I'm going into this movie and as long as
autobots and decepticons and robots and
they fight that'll be cool but it
concentrated too much on the human
characters and the human characters were
boring I didn't give a about them
even the Autobots were boring I didn't
give a about them it had that
stupid shitty ass michaelbay humor that
we're all sick of at this point and all
the Boom Boom Boom Boom Boom Boom Boom
Boom Boom Boom Boom Boom Boom Boom Boom
Boom annoyed the living out of me
at a point if I didn't give this movie
this writing it would just mean I don't
have the balls to do it I'm gonna have
the balls to do it transformers age of
extinction is when I am bored
shitless checking my watch hoping to god
the movies ending and I'm about halfway
through the movie that's a problem but
the transformers age of extinction have
you seen it what did you think about it
and not all opinions are gonna be the
same on this so a couple people walked
out of the movie a lot of them were like
wha
No but some people were like I love the
Transformers movies and I love that to
each their own so whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more